we are at the Comedy Store and these
three girls there and Chris is standing
here and one of the girls goes I'm not
drinking right now and finkles why
excuse because I'm on the spiritual path
Chris goes and that's what a crazy
person so important to say that oh wait
you would like this you know what I did
this this is the kind of thing that I
was talking about so you know what the
comedies you know what you would you
would you would [ __ ] piss yourself
all right so we're at the Comedy Store
I was with like five friends that I
hadn't seen for a long time and you know
how when you're at the Comedy Store are
really any comedy club in LA there's
always like a few outliers and you're
like and they're like kind of listening
to your conversation and you're like is
this person a comedian does he do open
mics or is he just wearing a jacket you
know I mean yeah
so I was doing this [ __ ] talking and we
were all having fun and this guy would
be like huh yeah yeah yeah and every now
and then he would say something and then
he and and would interview I haven't
seen in a while like one of my cast
mates from undateable and [ __ ] like that
and he says something one other time
while we're laughing and we're doing a
bit and in the middle of the bit he says
something and in the middle of me
laughing I said who are you bro you're
in this we're all rally broke his heart
that's the things okay so you should
know that like yeah oh just don't have a
sense of place you to be that guy he
goes uh just backed up into a new room
yeah if he doesn't know who he is dude
in the [ __ ] bro know who you are dude
that's the first thing you get out of
your card you're somewhere who dare is
new
you know the learning how to behave like
I know not to I don't know them so I'm
not gonna be like I did it once I did it
once recently dude but you can do it
every now and then because you're not
that guy you understand your and I felt
like that guy was doing it well go is
remember what it was oh yeah
every time then I'll do it too but yeah
I was that okay try to be on your team
note the circle is opening up yeah okay
okay okay um I was at Logan Paul's um
home where he does his podcast and
Machine Gun Kelly was there Machine Gun
Kelly right yeah he's good
so he's like we're like waiting outside
to go on to the show where they tape and
he was like there was some friends and I
walked up I was gonna introduce myself
and then I got nervous so now really
just standing there but dude I was
stranded there was night sometimes I
wanted to be appropriate like it's
obvious and I can feel everybody's
energy they know now I the song it's too
late to bail it wasn't leave you looking
yeah a dude and I started getting scared
like I didn't know what was going on or
who I was that I had this happen I was
thought I had this happen on the podcast
on Monday because they shoot that all
the all the smoke the MBA show it was
like summer jam in there bunch of black
guys everywhere Dwyane Wade's there
Steph Curry's there and I find my like
they drop me in there and I'm in the
circle they're all clock and I didn't
know what this all no and so I went what
urban with I went man but man those
wings oh oh man and those wings are off
the chain oh wow dude I've never said
the chills wings are off the chain in my
entire funny life on this earth a lot of
people go bird when they meet brother
wings out of the chain I hate you
brother funny man no one had all [ __ ]
you want I learned my lesson so I'm the
white guy I'll see myself oh my god well
I was out I was 14 at boarding school
I just moved house kid my parents are in
Saudi Arabia still I want to be a
football player I didn't know that I
wasn't built for full-price Portland
it's on your dad that's what happens
when you come into America rich you
think he just be a football yes it's a
really good point
I'm gonna be a football player I want to
be a wrestler football I want to become
you in Vienna I wanted to be a
quarterback you want to be Joe Montana
yes I want to hear out of my you know I
would set goals so I like by the time
I'm a senior then I'll go to college I
had all plans to be able to like know
Montana Montana and it was it has come
here and be some yeah I did and I and
yes American dream dude go on [ __ ] in my
American dream I'm 14 yeah you're right
probably 95 pounds for real and I
remember the new New England the fall
would be so cool I was like I can't play
football too too cold I'm just not built
for any of so this the they're the three
older guys who are like kind of big and
they were good at football they were
talking on the bus and I'm her they were
having a conversation and I was so
excited that I was I couldn't wait to
get into wide excitement yeah like this
I couldn't wait I was so excited and I
said I never forgot I went like this I
said yeah I feel the same way and the
guy turned to me and he was like this he
goes yeah I feel the same way
Wow he's disappear I got so embarrassed
and I knew that I wasn't in this group
and I went and I went inside like I
never forgot it I still remember I went
hurt my feelings so badly but I'll never
[ __ ] up again I'll never make that
mistake again you got
he's gonna try though yours what I tried
there's one a little different than this
then then this but along the same lines
I'm walking home from school I must have
been in fifth or sixth grade okay I'm
walking home from school and there's the
hot girls they're walking together now I
was by no means a hot guy I was the
[ __ ] kid who was late to puberty yeah
and all the [ __ ] I had [ __ ] the big
feet when I was a cocky teen right oh
yeah and I'm walking with these girls
now and I'm like okay don't tell
anything to [ __ ] up this hill it's
fine peppered in some conversation
didn't really go well didn't do any
[ __ ] didn't you just kind of like a
head that wasn't good and that wasn't
good okay so I'm like oh man I'm
thinking about this I'm like maybe I'm
just not this guy maybe I could just let
it it's fine dude there's alphas around
I'm just a [ __ ] dork and it's all
good I remember my buddy Matt ravenna
and he was always like the [ __ ]
athlete version that he could play all
the sports and I couldn't and he was
with them too and they probably liked
him and I'm walking and I can't [ __ ]
pepper in good conversation now as this
is happening now this is all you can
take as a sixth sixth grader this is
what you can take yeah this is the
threshold okay now what happened was
there was a pothole okay now I didn't
see the pothole no all right I stepped
in the pothole as I'm already at this
threshold okay lower then now my guess
exactly now my now my now my knee bends
not only am I already at the tip-top of
I can take the glasses full right now
I'm in physical pain and I and I go and
I go no like mine like something come on
my mouth wrong way and I immediately
start leaking out of my eyes I'm crying
okay because I can't do it all right I
don't know we're too old to be crying so
I'm walking out details bro and you know
I may be fourth fifth grade I don't know
I don't you already said how young does
he have to be for you to enjoy the stuff
yeah
so so I start crying and I'm like oh my
god I'm so insecure that I'm crying all
right I know like who gives a [ __ ] now
if I go there all right it's time for
stead of my knee what's up right now I'd
be like uh-huh oh what's wrong I hyper
extend my knee you wanna [ __ ] you know
what I mean that's what you got to go
with jeez
even if you're married with kids you got
to be like let's [ __ ] so they know this
kinda means business yeah yeah we read
you wanna [ __ ] percent dude you meet you
the person is right next lo no no no no
no you don't meet to it okay all right
look man anyway so I start crying
now that's not the good part Shh the
hottest girl senses something's wrong
which is horrible
right so she says hey are you okay
which is worse cuz I'm crying
hyper-extended my knee I don't know how
to [ __ ] pepper in with the
conversation yeah how could she not know
that you're not okay there's so many
clues but I didn't want to be like well
I didn't know what to say in the
conversation and then I hyper-extended
my knee and I feel so insecure because
you probably like mattre venon right
that's you should have said it is what I
shouldn't that that what did you say but
what I said was I did the Hohner my pen
what I said was it always a mystery what
what I said was my grandma died ah I
like made up my grandma died oh great
and now I think I have to wait for my
grandma to die so so it like can make
sense she and updating you though no I
don't even know who it was it was just
the hot girl
oh but I made up that my grandma died
and I know what's my mom did well under
pressure though you think that's good
that's creative it was creative it's not
that creative it's an easy album yeah
everybody has a grandmother
first thing or basically the human
version of the hamster I die everybody
has a dead one I shoulda said my
great-grandmother died I should have
said my great-grandmother died because
she was dead right how do we learn right
you know I'm still young I could use it
but dude I'm fricking yeah did our one
time in San Francisco followed okay I
was interested in sorry I was interested
in this woman right this adult probably
I don't know anywhere from 20 to
probably four
he held are you to be I was 19 I think
or seven or 19 or 20 no she was 20 if
you were 20 but anyway but I was real
real nervous right and she was walking
mm-hmm and so I started walking right
and I was gonna I told my buddy I'm like
hey I'm gonna go talk to this lady right
and so next thing you know I've walked
like five blocks I'm behind her getting
closer but I'm too nervous to like talk
to her and then uh and then finally I
get up close to her and uh and the first
thing I said at this point I think she
knew that I've been following her for so
long I was like hey I'm not a stalker
I'm not go that's a good thing to open
with yeah I'm not trying to do is what
stalkers do yeah and then she [ __ ]
literally ran off this I'm not real it
was it was a little bit uphill it was
like second street yeah I'm friendly
with those guys the dead said put me in
my place those four bears i sat there I
felt so bad then I turned back around
and I looked at a mango when I get older
I'm gonna come into your house when
you're sleeping and I'm gonna cut your
throat what you said got older and I
made my first money on MADtv yeah
I hired a dude from New York to come in
and kill their entire families Ryan I
know that's not why you guys meeting
can't jokes on their back okay but now
this cops you're making listen to well
that's in and let him let him prove what
I know you tried trumping all of our
stories with that thing yeah I don't
think you slit you hired a guy yeah to
slit his throat for just kind of making
fun of you in the back of a bus killed
everybody you got to take your own life
dude if you really mean it that's right
let somebody else is the old [ __ ] yeah
now these days you get so angry at
somebody you [ __ ] take your own way
just you just cut yourself and bleed on
them
yeah whatever your little missy boy guys
you take your own life dude about any of
this don't be a [ __ ] you guys are a
three pack of [ __ ] boys
hey girl this girl hot you burn high
school is the worst it's the word most
impression with a girl goes hi how are
you and I go hey I'm great how are you
look at this hair it's amazing I'm touch
her and she goes like this I see her go
I said she's a girl
oh my god a hairdresser you a [ __ ] voice
how are you all in though I just I
stroked her hair that's not normally if
she was Tonto I remember what so you'd
be like hey what's up right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]